hey I'm Kristian harloff and I'm Tiffany
Smith and our guest today is the
director of the highly anticipated
horror movie Nerdist presents the hive
gave your legs are besties welcome yay
this is only three some movie Isom yeah
welcome to yaves corner I can intro our
awesome guest Dave you're Bucky I want
to hear more about the high few little
break down exactly what we should expect
it's a nonlinear puzzle type movie so I
don't want to tell you too much but i
will tell you you know someone wakes up
in a room and he's trying to figure out
why he's there and slowly these memories
start coming to him and and some of them
are his memories some of them are other
people's memories he's not sure why it's
channeling other people's memories and
all of it pieces together to tell this
big storm debris to see you talk about
original and different horror films one
of my favorites is slither now James
Gunn has watch this film James Gunn has
talked about this film he said it's the
most disgustingly gruesome love story
ever which to me none of those things go
together I know I know he liked the
movie we watched it together at
fantastic fest in Austin and I was
really nervous being my first film and
he could tell I was really nervous and
halfway through the movie he looked at
me and he was like don't be nervous it's
really good so apparently gruesomely
disgusting love stories are the next big
thing I'm into it yeah what something
I'm not into is my gruesomely disgusting
box-office pics they have not been good
on this show they have not been good at
all and every week we put our bucks on
the line one of the only saw the gummy
bears did see the massage so I saw last
week that you guys had a wager on
transporter refueled you bet six and you
bet 10 and the actual estimated
was for 7.2 which me loser oh my friends
who watched the episode and the movie
said I should have won I have friends
who watch the show I don't have any
friends I don't would you like me to
prove this to you okay free movie I'm
here with my front Chris Evans Chris do
you happen to know who won this week
Christian one this week sorry Ted
captain america in yo face Gasper
markovic says loser should raise their
hand whenever they want to speak no no
no you get we wish it and yet a lot of
words it's just like someone who
shouldn't be talking right and then I
get to talk you don't do that in school
you don't just read you know I got it
about you have to wait to be called on
right is what he said right so can you
do that I'll try okay all right so this
is what I guess what item I have armed
our crew over there over there over
there I'm going to have them hit you
unmercifully if you don't follow the
rules understood as I'm really sorry
yeah I like this so very much can I get
a gun it works this week's weekly wager
m night shyamalan has a brand new film
the visit I am going to say 16.5 million
for the visit Dave how do you feel about
that prediction did you like that oh
yeah go ahead I'm gonna go with 14 5
make sure you guys use that Jack loser
shut and let us know what you want the
loser do when they lose the weekly wager
next week she's probably gonna be
Christian but until we get there it's
time for today's topic
today's topic absolute legend that we
lost in West Craven yes why do you think
he meant so much to so many people well
he's scared a generation like everyone
my age is totally influenced and
affected by the things that he created
that does say a lot that it wasn't just
this terrifying thing that there was
something also that you responded to as
well I just remember what it was like
ready was everything to me growing up
like Freddy was the coolest you know
Freddie had comedy chops well he
eventually did but that wasn't I
wouldn't say those Wes yeah you got a
sniper foam dart shooter listen I can't
control with these people are you
serious that's probably a good idea
that's a great idea huh good idea this
is a huge subject change but people
under the stairs oh yeah I remember
begging my friend's parents to let their
kids my friends come with me to see
people as i was telling his goodies it's
just a little scarier than Goonies
tiffany smith you had a question i think
he does a great job of creating that
imagery where you just say people under
the stairs and like that's that
terrified all kids under the stairs
under the bed you have titles like
scream and then nightmare so I think
that brings us to something else right
now that's all about titles it's game
time cuz our own world theatre I'm gonna
give you guys the titles of movies that
are the opposite of what the title
actually isn't since we were talking
about Wes Craven today they're all gonna
be wes craven films whoever raises their
hand first gets to give the answer if
you get it right you get a point whoever
has the most points at the end wins and
gets to spend the winters wheels
for example live soft would be hard
exactly not raising your hand the loser
should is over for game time all right
but the shame lives on agreed the shame
lives on for one episode only your body
to give Dave my soul to take that is
correct next one is Frankenstein in
Queens Christian vampire in Brooklyn
nice a daydream on flower highway Dave
I'm nightmare on elm street hey hey the
first motel on the right Oh David last
house on the left this is I love that
move his hand thing I love that movie
yes raises man faster than you do yeah I
was terrible in school all right ready
the planes don't have ears Dave the
hills have eyes hope that I know these
this is fun I can do this all day the
next one is blue mouth read read read i
read that is crack ok old daydream new
nightmare you didn't raise your hand you
wanted that new nightmare yes that was
pretty brutal and i have to say Dave
kind of wiped the floor with you what's
Craven inspired as movies oh it's true
you showed up and played very well which
means that you get to spin the winners
wheel whatever you get see then we will
watch something here we'll hear
something do you make us do something
what happens for lands on the poop
that's do at this point just poop on the
floor I'm gonna poop on the floor please
what you got to show us I do happen to
have a clip from the hive that you guys
can see so show it I can tell you right
now that if we were in the theater
Tiffany would be digging her nails into
my arms yeah that's scary Dave sorry
watching and a big thank you today for
joining us make sure you guys head over
to nerdist.com get your tickets for that
one night only nationwide event and make
sure you follow him on social media and
make sure that you subscribe to this
YouTube channel here click like and
download the fandango movie clips app on
your smartphone and then join us back
here on movie brisa actually did not
raise her hand hand hand look at this
director being a director it's over that
was right in the boob